As your mobile device is busy
executing tasks, calculating
how to split a bar tab, and
uploading photos of your cat,
the underlying hardware is
effectively pulling energy
from your battery to
accomplish this work.
And as we've all seen,
the more work your device
does, the more battery it
pulls, and the sooner your users
are left holding onto
an uncharged phone that
doubles as a really
expensive doorstop.
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and the key
to writing applications that
are light on battery drain
has everything to do
with understanding
how the process
works under the hood.
See, in the electrical
engineering world,
this action of hardware
pulling energy from the battery
to execute a task is called
current draw over time.
And anyone who has
an undergraduate
in electrical
engineering will tell
you not every action
on your device
draws the same amount of
battery in the same way
over the same period of time.
To prove this, let's take
a handy Nexus 5 device,
turn it in airplane mode, and
then let it sit on our desk.
Now, if we leave the phone
like this doing nothing,
we'll roughly get
a month of life
before the battery is
completely exhausted.
We can consider this baseline.
But that's typically not how
these devices are actually
used.
As soon as you're
active with your device,
you're going to be
eating up more battery.
Now, active in this
context includes anything
like CPU doing work, booting
up the cellular radio
to transmit data, or the
screen itself being awake.
So the question is, what
tasks are my application
doing that are eating
up the most battery?
And sadly, this really
isn't an easy answer.
See, monitoring battery
drain at a hardware level
is a catch-22 because, of
course, the monitoring hardware
itself then needs to eat
up the phone's battery
in order to execute the actions
to record how much battery
is actually being drained.
As such, most devices that
aren't specialty don't do this.
The only real way to gather
these types of statistics
on battery draw is to attach a
third party piece of hardware
to your Android device which
can record these operations
without using up the
phone's power to do so.
Now, when we do this, we get
some really, really interesting
information.
For example, we can see
that when the Nexus 5 is
in standby mode, there's
actually not much power
drain going on, but when
we wake up our device
and turn on the
screen, we can see
there's a huge spike in
the battery monitor, which
you'd kind of expect.
Turning on the LEDs,
painting the screen, and then
all the CPU, GPU
work required to draw
on the screen isn't free from
a battery perspective which,
by the way, is completely
different than when
an application
wakes up the device,
say, if it's using a wakelock
or an alarm manager or a job
scheduler API.
When a device is
asleep and is woken up
through one of
these APIs, you'll
see an initial battery spike as
the processor first boots up,
followed by a bit of battery
draw as some work is executed.
Now, it's worth pointing out
that once the work is over,
the device will
go back to sleep,
and this is really important.
Sleep saves battery life.
If you forget to
let the device sleep
or are keeping the device
awake for long periods of time,
the battery is going to
become drained in no time.
Now, your mobile cellular
radio is a completely different
story, that is, anytime
your device tries
to send data over
the mobile network.
You can see that there is a
quick wakeup cost associated
with getting your mobile
hardware ready, followed
by a large spike for
sending out a packet
and receiving one back.
Now, because the
radio getting started
process is so
expensive, the hardware
itself will actually stay awake
for a short period of time
after it's done
executing work in case
there are more packets coming
its way from the network.
This is great data.
I mean, this is cool stuff,
but sadly, most developers
don't have access to
this kind of equipment.
Thankfully, with the
L release of Android,
we've got a whole
new set of tools
to help you optimize battery
draw for your application.
Firstly, users can see how
much battery your application
is drawing with the new
on-device battery details data.
You can access this by opening
Settings, clicking on Battery,
and then choosing your
application, at which point
you'll be provided
with key details
about how much time your
application is spending keeping
the phone awake or
doing networking tasks.
And trust me, if your
app's battery profile looks
like this, you
might be in trouble.
Secondly, there's
a brand new tool
that lets you visualize these
same battery eating actions
over the usage cycle
of your application.
The Battery
Historian tool allows
you to create a
timeline for each task
that you can easily see how
often, for example, your app
starts up the radio.
This information gives
you a clear target
for your battery
optimization efforts.
But honestly,
fixing these issues
is a whole separate
topic entirely,
which is why you need to check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns
content, which will teach you
the beautiful zen of
battery management.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.